es el partido grande que tenemos para
esta jornada de España Alemania aquí en
el estadio al B del estadio el segundo
estadio más grande que tenemos en esta
copa mundo el estadio del partido
inaugural de momento de poco ambiente
queda un poco más de dos horas para ese
partido no hemos notado todavía que esté
llegando aficiones a ese lugar
Igualmente no son precisamente las
aficiones germanas y la española las más
nutridas que hemos visto aquí pero sin
duda alguno es un partido grande dos
históricos que se miden esto en la
segunda jornada del grupo e y además que
vienen con ese antecedente de esas
victorias de Costa Rica contra Japón Eso
hace que pase lo que pase en este
encuentro entre españoles y alemanes
nada se va a decidir todavía y habrá que
esperar a la última y tercera jornada de
esta fase de grupos para saber quién de
estos cuatro equipos avanza hasta
octavos de final por parte de España que
viene de colear 7 a 0 a Costa Rica Se
esperan cambios sobre todo en la defensa
a nombres que no se van a tocar serían
emerick laport Sergio busquets pedre y
Gaby y en la delantera por parte de
Alemania que viene de esa sorpresiva
derrota contra Japón por dos a uno
Parece que la todo gira en torno así
finalmente Leroy sale podrá jugar con el
kit y con el 11 no alemán al igual que
también se especula con el ingreso de
León goresca en la medular son dos
equipos históricos Pero últimamente La
balanza se ha girado en favor de España
España eliminó a los germanos en la
semifinal del mundial de Sudáfrica le
ganaron una Eurocopa en 2008 y más de
recientemente los ibéricos golearon a
los hermanos también en la Liga de
Naciones